[Música]
[Aplausos]
isso é um boneco mais idiota de sempre
mas eu acho que vai estar o que eu acho
que é suficiente
só alguém falou em andar que sejam muito
bem vindos
um vídeo e os pessoal hoje nós vamos
fazer vídeo que vocês tanto pela lei
como elas está um amigo alerj eu tenho
que falar mais preocupa e está em casa
eu não fazia ideia que eu vou gravar
este vídeo portanto vamos aproveitar só
para você ter uma noção das horas
olha aí meia noite 25 já é plantar vi eu
não está a contar com este vídeo tem
muita coisa pra assustar o piloto em
questão médica que o comprei um aluno na
altura não usei porque caso isso
aconteça é muita coisa cumprimenta coisa
inclusive com essa coisa de me expor
tanto esses são os últimos vídeos só
porque o hotel tudo tem ficado aqui em
casa eu diria que esta boneca portanto
vamos aproveitar que provê de hoje o
principal assunto que vou dar opinião
vai ser vista na sala para isso o time
criou muito assustador atendimento
dentro aí vai se assustar muita que
neste vídeo só vamos tentar atingir uma
meta já muito rápido vamos tentar chegar
em uma hora aos 30 mil likes 30 mil xbox
quanto ele quer os 30 mm em uma hora eu
prometo que trago logo logo logo como
estava o amigo cebola só sei que vocês
conseguem também tentou colocar um vídeo
por dia thomaz forçar muito portanto
quanto com as ajudas 30 mil leques em
uma hora e eu faço como estarão amigos é
cubana assim tanta coisa que eu vou
estar aqui também pra assustar o pio
voltar aqui um exclusivo que nunca usei
eu não sei ao certo como é que se chama
seu como pesquisa no youtube o pessoal
chama isso de estúdio o faz muito
barulho e vai estar com certeza eu nem
fazer só jogava futebol brincava como
guarda e esse tipo de coisas do ano com
seis títulos vamos usar aqui hoje então
quando conversa ajuda pessoal e para lá
então começar o congo
vou ter que falar baixo por conquistar
no quarto ao lado o bora lá ainda não é
o que possui estava a tentar fazer aqui
uma gravação mais agressivo é só pra ter
piada nenhum evento na minha mão como se
fosse uma frágil como assim inovação mil
roubados
o 4/4 embora lá
[Música]
o amigo que isso não é e quem estava
fazendo e os levavam naquele show mesmo
em bairros frei perigoso mas não não não
saiu
hoje nós vamos gravar o como a história
única tsu é isso que se viu
[Música]
[Aplausos]
o ano ethernet e leitor
[Música]
[Aplausos]
[Risadas]
[Música]
[Aplausos]
a sala de tv porque foi sempre de
madrugada eu vou falar com cada câmera
eu não sei se ela vai ficar sem padre
mas vai lá ficar a filmar até o bicheiro
espero que o vejatv porque não vai ser
só uma tentativa falhada mas vamos fazer
isso eu vou colocar a câmera não há
estratégia e cinco pisos sentar e ver tv
vamos lançar a nossa única acima
só não acho que a cinta prefeito agora
vamos descansar preocupe para estar aqui
e ver tv ou cair vamos só esperar só os
planos de voltar a comer comigo e ela
vai perceber que neste canto
não né
ae
[Música]
[Aplausos]
acho que o objetivo do jogador é isso
que está aqui comigo
a bola já não tem graça nenhuma guia é
deixar a china em casa 2 muito estúpido
como está com vocês nunca havia lançado
[Música]
[Aplausos]
i was tudo
[Música]
até aqui mas neste ano os cultos cuida
da manhã de hoje mais dois no imt um
balanço da edição de 1995 foi comigo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
[Risadas]
o aluno tem os seus parceiros mais
incrível aqui neste vídeo e como
assistente de blanc nossa voz misteriosa
nesse caso vai ser um palhaço como é que
nós vamos voltar aqui a armadilha eu vou
estar lá embaixo na cozinha o que vai
mexer eu vou chamar os eu não tiro o
chapéu obrigatório e mesmo eu pensar que
o outro estado mas o que eu não estava à
espera é que eu vou estar na cozinha
portanto não gostou porque eu já estou
mas o que não espera é que está um
palhaço por baixo de máquina de lavar
louça porque nós mandamos a máquina de
lavar louça arranjar portanto temos um
espaço onde ela vai entrar pode
estressar opinião vai estar à espera
portanto vai ser um susto aqui do vídeo
espero que corra bem tiveram um susto
muito senão eu tentei eu tentei mas para
lá
as estórias em bem essa mesma
[Música]
acreditamos que é muito difícil
ele é é um homem que eu estava lá quando
voltou com determinações ou música aqui
embaixo dos 50
[Música]
eu acho que nós fazemos um treino aqui
os atingidos o ppi caiu que sabia que
ela estava lhe assistem muito bem vai
estar obrigatoriamente of acabar
vem cá você ajuda a formar a loja
novas ruas já estava decidida há dois
anos quando ele diz que não vai apenas a
formação então isso é uma só o torcedor
[Aplausos]
[Música]
quer isso aqui essa estrela o veículo
precisa mas não vamos continuar aqui no
canal é dona a como estruturada com uma
tranquila dos dois olhos
olha olha olha a missão cumprida e não
só lá se foi o como a citar um amigo
sérgio espero que vocês tenham gostado
já sabe alexei muito lá e aqui no vídeo
muito obrigado a voz misteriosa por ter
compactuado com a minha missão é burro
amanhã o estudo não é vender seu próprio
ser frio é boa para continuar estudando
não há nenhum estado fica na etapa o
brasil mal eu fiquei com a dança do
palhaço louco
[Música]
tudo era transformada